สวัสดีค่ะสค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูเรียม
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะสดี
ค่ะกลับมาพบกลับกลับกลับกลับมาพบกับกลับ
นะคะนักเรียนกลับกลับครูฟ้าครูเรียมในใช่
แล้ววดีโอ beginner ใช่มั้ยคะครูเรียมใช่
ค่ะวันนี้ที่เรามาเจอกันมาคุยกันเป็นวัน
อะไรคะวันนี้เนี่ยเป็นวันวันพุธค่ะครู
เรียมวันพุธวันพุธวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันพุธ
ที่ 31 หือ 31 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
สิงหาคมเดือน
สิงหาคมอืโอเสิหปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
[เพลง]
2565 แล้วปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
20  22 ค่ะโอเคตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา 14
น 22 นโอ 22 น 2  2  2  2  2  2  2  2  2
2 ทำไมเลข 2 เยอะมากๆเลยนะคะเรียมเลข 2
ค่ะแล้วก็ออวันนี้ก็เป็นวันสิ้นเดือนด้วย
นะใช่วันสุดท้ายนะคะ 31 เนี่ยวันสุดท้าย
ของเดือนสิงหาคมหรือว่าเดือนที่ 8 อใช่ก็
เป็นวันสิ้นเดือนใช่วันสิ้นเดือนแล้วค่ะ
วันสิ้นเดือนวันที่ 1 ต่อไปก็วันที่ 1 ก็
เป็นวันต้นเดือนเนาอืมวันที่ 1 วัน
พฤหัสบดีเนาะวันที่ 1 นะคะวันที่ 1 โอเค
วันสิ้นเดือนแบบนี้เนี่ยครูฟ้าก็เลยมี
เรื่องดีๆนะคะมาเล่าให้ครูเรียมแล้วก็นัก
เรียนฟัง
อืมีเรื่องอะไรคะครูฟ้าเกี่ยวกับแบบได้
เงินหรอสิ้นเดือนบางคนก็ได้เงินเดือนแบบ
เนี้ยใช่เกี่ยวกับการได้เงิน
ได้อะไรที่เราอยากได้นะคะเงิน
ทองดีจังเลยอ่ะทำไมอ่ะครูเรียมแต่ว่าเป็น
เรื่องของใครเรื่องของครูฟ้าเหรอคะไม่ใช่
ค่ะเรื่องนี้เนี่ยเป็นเรื่องของผู้ชายคน
นึงค่ะครเหรี่ยมผู้ชายคนนึงอืมผู้ชายคน
นี้เนี่ยเค้า
เป็นชาว
ประมงชาวประมุงอ่าชาวประมุงใช่ค่ะเคยได้
ยินมั้ยมีอาชีพเค้าทำงานเป็นชาวประมุง
เหรอคะใช่ค่ะทำงานเป็นชาวประมุงก็คือเขา
ก็จะไปที่ทะเลใช่มั้ยชาวประมงเก็จะอยู่
ที่ทะเลแล้วก็จับปลาค่ะอือ๋อมีปลาก็ไปจับ
ปลาอืมชาวประมงเนี่ยจับปลาแล้วก็ขายขาย
ขายอันนี้คือเป็นชาวประมงนะคะคือคนจับปลา
นั่นแหละอืผู้ชายคนนี้เนี่ยนะคะที่ครูฟ้า
เล่าให้ฟังเนี่ยเขาก็เป็นชาวประมงค่ะครู
เรียมเป็นชาวประมงแล้วก็มีภรรยา 1 คนอืม
อ๋ออยู่ด้วยกันนะีิแล้วค่ะมีมีแค่คนเดียว
มีคนเดียวค่ะมีคนเดียวภรรยา 1 คนเท่านั้น
ไม่มีลูกนะคะไม่มีลูกอืแล้ว
ก็อยู่ด้วยกันที่บ้านเป็นบ้านเล็กๆนะคะ
บ้านเล็กมากอืบ้านแบบไม่มีเงินนะค่ะครู
เรียไม่มีเงินแบบจนจอ๋ออยู่แบบไม่มีเงิน
แล้วเอยากมีลูกมั้ยคะครูฟ้าเค้าเนี่ยยัง
ไม่อยากมีลูกค่ะเพราะว่าเขาไม่มีเงินไง
อ๋อใช่มั้ยอถ้ามีลูกเนี่ยก็ต้องมีเงินขอ
ซัพพอร์ตลูกนะคะแต่ว่า 2 คนสามีภรรยา
เนี่ยไม่มีเงินสามีนะคะผู้ชายเนี่ยก็จะไป
ตกปลาทุกวันเนาะไปตกปลาหรือว่าไปจับอืม
จับปลาทุกวัน
เอ่าตกปลาเนี่ยก็คือจะต้องมีที่ตกปลาใช่
มั้ยมีเบ็ดมีเบ็ดแบบนี้ใช่
มก็จะมีอะไรตรงเยตรงกล่มๆเอามั้ยใช่
อ่าใช่ค่ะครูเรียมอันนี้เบ็ดอืเบ็ดตกปลา
ตกปลาจะได้เอาปลาไปขายไงผู้ชายคนนี้เนี่ย
ก็ออกไปตกปลาทุกวันนะคะออกไปตกปลาทุกวัน
แต่ว่ามีอยู่วันนึงเนี่ยก็ไปตตกปลาปกติ
แต่ปลาที่ได้มาเนี่ยมันพูดได้ค่ะครูเรียม
ปลาตัวนี้ปลาพูดแบบเฮ้สวัสดีครูป้าใช่่
ปลาพูดภาษาคนได้นะคะปกติปลาพูดไม่ได้ใช่
ไหมนักเรียนแต่ปลาตัวนี้เนี่ยมันสเปเชียล
มากมันพูดได้อืปลาก็พูดกับผู้ชายคนนี้นะ
คะว่า
อย่าจับฉันไปเลยอย่าฆ่าฉันเลยปลาพูดนะปลา
พูด
อืจริงๆแล้วฉันไม่ใช่ปลาอ้าจริงเหรอเรียม
กำลังจะถามว่าชาวประมงตกใจมั้ยอืชาวประมง
ก็ตกใจนั่นแหละค่ะแต่เขาก็ฟังที่ปลาพูด
เนาะอือฟังที่ปลาพูดนะคะแล้วก็ปลาก็บอก
ว่าจริงๆแล้วฉันไม่ใช่
ปลาแต่ว่าฉันเป็นเจ้าชายอืมเป็นเจ้า
ชายใช่ค่ะเป็นเจ้าชายนะคะเป็นเจ้าชายรสึก
ว่าจะมีเจ้าชายอยู่หลายๆที่เจ้าชายอยู่ใน
สตอรี่ทุกเรื่องที่ครูฟ้าเล่าเลยนะคะนัก
เรียนปลาตรงนี้เนี่ยบอกว่าฉันเนี่ยไม่
อร่อยหรอกกินเข้าไปก็ไม่อร่อยใช่มยหืไม่
อร่อยปล่อยฉันไป
เถอะคนหาปลาก็บอกว่าอืม
เออเนาะปลาพูดได้มันแปลกนะคะอืคนหาปลาก็
เลยคิดไม่ฆ่าปลาตัวนี้ก็ปล่อยลงไปในทะเล
อือ๋อปล่อยลงไปในทะเลนะคะ
พอคนหาปลาคนจับปลาเอ่อชาวประมงแล้วกันนะ
คะชาวประมงที่ครูฟ้าบอกเนาะชาวประมงก็
ปล่อยปลลาไปแล้วก็เดินกลับบ้านนะคะเดิน
กลับบ้านอ้าแล้ววันนั้นชาวประมงได้ปลา
กลับไปที่บ้านไหมไม่ได้เลยค่ะครูเอมอไม่
ได้เลยอืแต่ว่าใจดีนะที่ปล่อยป่าตัวนั้น
ไปใช่เป็นคนใจดีนะคะพอกลับไปถึงที่บ้าน
แล้วเนี่ย
ภรรยาก็ถามว่าวันนี้ได้ปลามา
มยชาวปมงก็บอกว่าไม่
อืแต่จริงๆฉันจับปลาได้ 1 ตัวนะอืแต่ปลา
ตัวนั้นเนี่ยมันเป็นเจ้าชายฉันก็เลยปล่อย
ไปปล่อยไปนะคะโอแล้วแบบนี้ภรรยาเชื่อมั้ย
คะว่าปลาเป็นเจ้าชายภรรยาก็บอกว่าเอ้าถ้า
ปลาตัวนั้นเป็นเจ้าชายมันก็น่าจะมีเมจิกม
ทำไมเราไม่ขออะไรจากปลาตัวนั้น
ล่ะ
ขอ
อืชาวประมงก็บอกว่าฉันไม่รู้ว่าจะขออะไร
ไม่รู้จะขออะไรนะคะไม่มีไอเดียเลยเนาะคิด
ไม่ออกเหรอแสดงว่าชาวประมงไม่ใช่คนไทยใช่
ไม่ชอบขอคนไทยชอบขอนะคะถ้าเป็นคนไทยก็อาจ
จะแบบเอ่อลอตเตอรี่ล็อตเตอรี่จะมีตัวเลข
อะไรบ้างอืจะขอไม่ใช่ชาวประมงไม่ใช่คนไทย
ค่ะกรียแต่ภรรยาน่าจะเป็นคนไทยนะคะเพราะ
ภรรยาบอกว่า
เอ้าตอนเนี้ยบ้านของเราเนี่ยมันเล็กแล้ว
มันก็เก่า
มากบ้านไม่โอเคเลยทำไมคุณไม่ขอบ้านมาล่ะ
ภรรยาก็ถามอืน่าจะขอบ้านนะแล้วสามีว่ายัง
ไง
คะสามีก็
อืมแต่ฉันปล่อยมันไปแล้วภรรยาก็บอกให้
สามีเนี่ยกลับไปที่ทะเลนะคะแล้วก็ไปหาปลา
ตัวนั้นไปคุยกับปลาตัวนั้นไปขอบ้านทะเล
หรือบ่อน้ำนี่ทะเลหรือบ่อน้ำนั่นสิปลามัน
จะมาหรอแต่สามีเนี่ยก็ต้องฟังภรรยาใช่มย
ก็เลยต้องเดินกลับไปหาปลาตัวนั้นค่ะเดิน
กลับไปอืมสามีที่ดีสามีที่ดีจริงๆสามี
เนี่ยไม่อยากขออะไรแต่ภรรยาพูดสามีก็ฟัง
ก็เดินกลับไปหาปลาตัวนั้นนะคะแล้ว
ก็ไปเรียกปลาเจ้าปลา
เออปลาที่เป็นเจ้าชายน่ะอยู่ที่ไหนคะชัน
มีเรื่องอยากจะขออันนี้ปลาหรือว่าจีนี่คะ
อาลดินรือเปล่าคิดคิดเหมือนกันจีนี่หรรือ
เปล่าแล้วปลาก็ได้ยินด้วยนะใช่มั้ยใช่ค่ะ
ครูเรียมปลาก็เลยว่ายน้ำขึ้นมาแล้วก็ถาม
ว่าอะไรจะขอ
อะไรผู้ชายนะคะที่เป็นชาวประมงเนี่ยก็เลย
บอกว่าภรรยาของฉันอยากได้บ้าน 1 หลัง
อืมออยากได้บ้าน 1 หลังบ้านน่ารักๆรบ้าน
หลังเล็กๆไม่ต้องใหญ่มากอืมอยากได้บ้าน 1
หลังนะคะแล้วปลาให้บ้านกับชาวประมงมั้ยคะ
ปลาก็บอกว่า
โอเคคุณกลับบ้านไปคุณก็จะเห็นมีบ้าน
ใหม่อยู่เรียบร้อยแล้วปลาเนี่ยที่เป็น
เจ้าชายนะนะคะก็ให้ตามที่ชาวประมงขออืม
ชาวประมงก็เลยเดินกลับไปที่บ้านพอเดิน
กลับไปถึงบ้านแล้วเนี่ยก็เห็นว่าภรรยาของ
เค้าเนี่ยเปลี่ยนไปอยู่ในบ้านที่ใหญ่ขึ้น
แต่ว่าก็เล็กๆนะไม่ได้ใหญ่มากนะคะเป็น
บ้านที่ใหญ่กว่าบ้านเก่าอืมแล้วก็บ้าน
เนี่ยน่ารักมากเลยนะคะก็เป็นบ้านที่ดี
เนาะเป็นบ้านที่ดีอืแล้วก็อยู่ด้วยกันกับ
พระภรยาอย่างมีความสุขใช่มั้ยคะมีความสุข
มย
น้าเหมือนว่าสามีก็จะมีความสุขแล้วนะคะ
แต่ภรรยา
เนี่ยยังไม่ค่อยมีความสุขเท่าไหร่เลยทำไม
คะทำไมไม่มีความสุขภรรยาเนี่ยพออยู่บ้าน
หลังนี้ไปได้ 1 อาทิตย์ 2 อาทิตย์ภรรยาก็
พูด
ว่าสามี
บ้านของเรามันเล็ก
จังอยู่ไปนานๆมันเล็กรู้สึกว่ามันเล็กนะ
อยากได้บ้านใหญ่กว่าเอ่ะอืเค้าก็สร้างสิ
ค่ะสร้างบ้านให้ใหญ่มากขึ้นไม่ไม่ต้อง
สร้างจะสร้างทำไมล่ะเรามีปลาไงเจ้าชายอ่ะ
อ๋อจะให้สามีไปขอปลาอีกหรอใช่ค่ะคูเรียม
ภรรยาก็บอกว่าสามีคุณไปหาปลาเจ้าชายตัว
นั้นแล้วก็ไปขอบ้านหลังใหญ่ขึ้นได้
มยสามีว่ายังไง
คะสามีก็บอก
ว่าบ้านหลังใหญ่อีกอ่ะหรอภรยาก็บอกใช่
อยากอยู่บ้านหลังใหญ่
เอิ่มอยากได้บ้านหลังใหญ่มากๆอยากอยู่ใน
ปราสาทปราสาท
หินอ๋อปราสาทหินปราสาทหินเป็นแบบนี้เลย
เหรอคะใช่ค่ะครูเรียมอันนี้คือปราสาทหิน
เห็นมั้ยโหมันใหญ่มากเลยนะมันใหญ่มากใช่
ค่ะครูเรียมมันใหญ่มากปราสาทนี่คือเหมือน
โหอยู่ได้ 100 คนเลยะใหญ่มากใช่ใช่แต่เขา
จะอยู่กัน 2 คนใช่มั้ยคะครูฟ้าใช่ค่ะเขา
จะอยู่กัน 2 คนค่ะครูเรี่ยมซึ่งสมีก็บอก
ว่าบ้านก็ดีอยู่แล้วบ้านตอนเนี้ยที่เรา
อยู่เนี่ยโอเคแล้วนะทำไมอยากอยู่ปราสาท
หินแต่ภรรยาก็โมโหแล้วก็บอกว่าฉันอยาก
อยู่ปราสาทหินฉันอยากอยู่บ้านใหญ่ๆคุณไป
หาปลาตัวนั้นไปหาไปหาปลาตัวนั้นเดี๋ยวนี้
บอกให้สามีไปหาปลานะคะสามีก็เลยเฮ้อโอเค
ไปก็ได้อ๋อก็ไปหาปาปลาใช่สามีก็เดินไปที่
ทะเลแล้วก็ไปเรียกเจ้าปลาเจ้าปลาปลาที่
เป็นเจ้าชายอยู่ที่ไหนฉันมีเรื่องอยากจะ
ขอ
อืปาประมามั้ยคะปลาก็ขึ้นมาค่ะครเรียม
ขึ้นมาแล้วก็บอก
ว่าต้องการขอ
อะไรชาวประมงเนี่ยก็บอกว่าภรรยาของฉัน
อยากได้บ้านที่มันใหญ่กว่านี้อยากได้บ้าน
แบบปราสาทหินให้ได้มยขอได้มยเออปลาก็เลย
บอกโอเคฉันให้ได้นะคะให้ได้คุณกลับไปตอน
นี้จะเจอปราสาทหินให้ผู้ชายคนเยกลับชาว
ประมงก็เดินกลับเดินกลับไปที่บ้านพอมาถึง
เนี่ยก็ไม่มีบ้านอีกแล้วเปลี่ยนเป็น
ปราสาทหินค่ะคูเรียมใหญ่มากใหญ่มากใหญ่
มากใหญ่มากใช่ก็แบบเป็นไงคะภรรยามีความ
สุขหรือยังภรรยาก็แฮปปี้ค่ะมีความสุขแล้ว
ก็เดินเข้าไปดูในปราสาทปราสาทเนี่ยใหญ่
ใช่มยก็จะมีห้องนอนห้องกินข้าวห้องทำ
อาหารมี
แชนเดอเลียมีอะไรสวยๆเยอะเลยมีไวนมีอาหาร
อะไรเต็มเลยนะคะแล้วก็มีม้าเออมีสัตว์
เต็มไปหมดอ้าวอืก็น่าจะมีความสุขดีแล้ว
เนาะใช่สามีก็เลยบอกอ่ะเราได้ปราสาทแล้ว
เราก็จะสบายแล้วเนาะสามีก็บอกภรรยาก็เลย
บอกว่าเดี๋ยวค่อยคุยกันตอนเนี้ยไปนอนก่อน
ภรรยาก็เข้าไปนอนนะคะแล้วก็อยู่ในปราสาท
เนี่ยประมาณ 2
อาทิตย์อืแล้วเกิดอะไรขึ้นคะครูฟ้าภรรยา
ก็ก็บอกสามีว่า
สามีฉันคิดว่าตอนเเรามีปราสาทแล้วนะอืเรา
มีปราสาทแล้วแล้วทำฉันอยากเป็น
ราชินีราชินีอยากเป็นควีนนะคะราชินีอ้าว
แล้วจะเป็นได้มั้ยอ่ะ
ใช่แล้วทำไมถึงต้องเป็นราชินีล่ะฉันก็จะ
เป็นพระราชาใช่มั้ยสามีถามนะคะสามีถามว่า
ทำไมเราต้องอยากเป็นพระราชาด้วยเอ้าภรรยา
ก็บอก
ว่าเราเนี่ยถ้าเราเป็นราชากับราชินีเนี่ย
เราก็จะมีคนเยอะๆมีพาวเวอร์มากๆไงอืก็เลย
บอกให้สามีเนี่ยไปขอกับปลาตัวนั้น
หูแล้วสามีคิดยังไงบ้างคะสามีอ่ะคิดว่า
มันไม่โอเคนะแบบเนี้ยมันไม่โอเคแล้วมัน
ไม่ถูกนะคะมันไม่ถูกถ้าเกิดเกิดเป็นแบบ
นี้เนี่ยเราก็จะขอขอๆขอมากขึ้นเรื่อยๆขอ
ทุกวันทุกเดือนทุกปีอืสามีเนี่ยไม่อยากไป
นะคะแต่ภรรยาพูดก็ต้อง
ไปพอไปถึงเนี่ยก็ไปเรียกเจ้าปลาเจ้าปลา
ปลาที่เป็นเจ้าชายอยู่ที่
ไหนปลาก็ขึ้นมานะคะแล้วก็น้ำในทะเลเนี่ย
ก็เริ่มเหม็นอืน้ำในทะเลเนี่ยเริ่มเหม็น
เกิดอะไรขึ้นคะครูฟ้ารู้มั้ยนั่นน่ะสิ
เกิดอะไรขึ้นก็ไม่รู้นะคะน้ำทะเลเนี่ย
เปลี่ยน
ไปซึ่งปาก็ถามว่าอยากได้
อะไรสามีก็เลยบอกว่าภรรยาของฉันอยากเป็น
ราชินีปลาก็เลยบอกว่ากลับไปหาภรรยาซะตอน
เนี้ยภรรยาได้เป็นราชินีแล้วว้าวอืปลา
โอเคค่ะสามิก็เดินกลับไปโอ้ที่ปราสาทหิน
เนี่ยมีทหารมีคนมีอะไรเยอะขึ้นเลยนะคะ
แล้ว
ก็เห็นราชินีเนี่ยใส่
มงกุฎเวลาเป็นเป็นราชินีต้องมีมงกุฎใช่
มั้ยมีมงกุฎนะคะมงกุฎใส่มงกุฎแพงมากแล้ว
ก็นั่งอยู่ทุกอย่างดูดีนะคะดูดีอืมซึ่ง
อ่ะตอนนี้สามีก็พูดว่าเรามีความสุขแล้ว
เนาะอืเพราะว่าเธอเป็นราชินีแล้วภรรยาก็
เลยบอกว่า
อืมเดี๋ยวค่อยพูดเดี๋ยวค่อยคุยกันอืตอน
นี้ก็มีความสุขไปก่อนแล้วกันเนาะก็ใช้
ชีวิตอยู่ไปอีก 2 อาทิตย์ค่ะครูเรียม
ภรรยาก็บอกว่าเร็วมากภรรยาบอกว่าฉันไม่
ฉันเนี่ยเป็นราชินี
ละตอนเนี้ยอยากเปลี่ยนไป
เป็นราราชินีของหลายๆประเทศเป็นเจ้าของ
โลกใบนี้
อ๋ออืเห็น
มสามีเนี่ยรู้สึกว่าแบบนี้มันไม่ได้แล้ว
นะคะแบบนี้มันไม่โอเคแล้วก็คิดว่าอเราไม่
มีความสุขเลยไอ้สิ่งที่เราได้มาเนี่ยทำไม
ภรรยาถึงไม่มีความสุขสักทีทำไมภรรยาไม่
แฮปปี้ล่ะตั้งแต่บ้านใช่มยบ้านหลังเล็กๆ
ปราสาทหินเป็นราชินี
ก็ประมาณ 2 อาทิตย์แล้วภรรยาก็ไม่อยากได้
อยากได้อะไรที่มากขึ้นนะคะสมีก็คิดทำไม
ภรรยาไม่มีความสุขแล้วเคทำยังไงคะสามีก็
เลยเดินกลับไปหาปลาแล้วก็เรียกเจ้าปลาปลา
ที่เป็นเจ้าชายอยู่มยอืปลาก็ขึ้นมาแล้วก็
ถาม
ว่ามีอะไรจะขออะไร
สามีก็เลยบอกว่าขอให้ภรรยาของฉันมีความ
สุขได้มยมีความสุขขอได้มั้ยเออกับสิ่งที่
มีอ่ะมีความสุขพอแล้วไม่อยากได้อะไรมาก
กว่านี้ปลาตัวนั้นก็บอกว่า
โอเคตอน
เนี้ยคุณกลับไปที่บ้านภรรยาจะมีความสุขออ
พอสามีเดินกลับมาที่บ้านกลายเป็นว่าทุก
อย่างหายไปหมดเลยค่ะปราสาทหินก็หายไปทหาร
ก็หายไป
ราชินีภรรยาที่เป็นราชินีก็ไม่มีอีกแล้ว
เหลือแค่ภรรยาคนเดิมแล้วก็บ้านหลังเล็กๆ
บ้านหลังที่ 1 เหมือนเดิมทุกอย่างเหมือน
เดิมหมดเลยก็คือภรรยาก็จะมีความสุขแบบที่
ไม่ต้องอยากได้อะไรมากกว่านี้อีกแล้วนี่
ไงนี่ก็เป็นอสอรี่นะคะนิทานี้ใช่ค่ะออ๊คน
ชาวประมงกับภรรยาของเค้ามจริงหรอเค้ามี
ความสุขจริงๆหรอภรรยาเลืมไปเลยหรอว่าเค
เคยเป็นราชินีครูฟ้าว่าน่าจะลืมนะคะลืมไป
เลยว่าเคยมีบ้านใหญ่เคยมีปราสาทหินเคย
เป็นราชินีลืมไปเลยอืมโห
ตเจ้าชายปลานี่ถ้าเกิดมีเวทมนตร์ขนาดนี้
ทำไมถึงต้องไปเป็นปลานั่นสิทำไมถึงต้องไป
เป็นปลาด้วยคะรู้อาจจะช่วยช่วยคนอื่นได้
แต่ช่วยตัวเองไม่ได้หรือเปล่าออเป็นเจ้า
ชายปลาแบบเเหหรอใช่อาจจะเป็นเจ้าชายปลาก็
ได้นั่นแหละวันนี้ก็เป็นเค้าก็บอกว่าถ้า
เรามีความสุขกับสิ่งที่เรามีใช่มยบ้านแบบ
นี้โอเคแล้วรถแบบนี้โอเคแล้วโทรศัพท์ของ
ทุกอย่างเงินเท่านี้โอเคแล้วเราก็อาจจะ
มีความสุขก็ได้นะคะครูมใช่ไม่ต้องไปหา
อะไรที่อย่างอื่นที่มากมายมันก็แล้วแต่
เกินไปกว่าตัวเราเนาะเอออาจจะมากเกินไป
ใช่มีเยอะๆมีมากขึ้นบางคนอาจจะไม่มีความ
สุขอาจจะไม่หรือว่าถ้าเกิดมีมากขึ้นแล้ว
ก็ให้เรามีความสุขด้วยใช่ว่ามันก็ได้นะคน
ที่มีเงินคือคนที่มีความสุขใช่มั้ยคะใช่
ใช่ก็ได้ก็จะแต่ว่าวันนี้เวลาหมดแล้วใช่
มั้ยคะคะครูฟ้าใช่ค่ะครูเรียมวันนี้เวลา
ลงหมดแล้วเดี๋ยวเราต้องเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอ
หน้าแล้วนะคะนักเรียนถ้าอย่างงั้นก็ใช่
ค่ะวันนี้ต้องลาไปก่อนแล้วค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบายนัก
เรียนบ๊ายบายค่ะนัก
เรียน